[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
siraga annonce
gad madic venez venez aloi revenez
franck vous allez regarder ce qu'il y a
ce qu'il ya derrière
derrière chaque cabine vous allez devoir
vraiment décrire à chaque fois qu'il ya
une meuf le faire on peut faire des
trucs conserva on va bien
gad allez-y vous allez démarrer mais
qu'est ce que je fais pour garder et
vous dites vous décrivez votre cabine
ici vous regardez discrètement ce qu'ici
non mais sur les convaincre que
jean-michel merkel meuf qu'on va dire
qu'on m'a dit que vous regardez ici neuf
ans vous allez voir il va choisir une
des deux cabinets va devoir embrasser la
personne qu'il ya derrière la cabine
d'accord attention moi je regarde wave
dernière tout à fait tout de manière
tout à fait regardons attention c'est
bon c'est bon
franck et malik et ouais moi je crois
que tu déconnes et allons même la non
pardon alors c'est jean michel maire qui
mâchouille attention et je peux pas moi
y aller plutôt et et vous franck qu'est
ce que vous voyez moi je vois mon père
j'ai fait des erreurs j'ai payé mon père
alors j'aurais fait ça même sans même
laisser réponse je viens mais je veux
bien échanger ma place
alors j'ai envie siège sent le piège je
vais bien et je me sens très bien
[Applaudissements]
plutôt tendance à les mères frères vas-y
mon père alors vous prenez franck oui
c'est mieux
vous insistez ou pas ses bisous bisous
avec la langue dans ce pack ouais smac
améliorer pas si c'est la belle-mère
langue si on serait la même chose alors
attention vous prenez ça allait aller où
ils gagnent provient sur wii il prenait
pas garde
grand gagnant ou frau non je prends
franck franck est mal est fait on va
voir tout de suite ce qu'il y avait
derrière lente et aux rideaux de gad
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
hébert et
ça peut être tout et n'importe où alors
attention tuant michel ne regardez pas
non alors gaga de gad et sabrina qui
sont ils et qui a 10 avril à une bombe
de meuf
non mais non elle est magnifique gad oui
quoi valider des courbes des courbes
d'audience franck gastambide moi j'ai la
meilleure série de cabinda meuf
jean-michel qu'est-ce que vous prenez
garde époux frank qu'elle puisse vous
allez très vite à gad gad
alors attendez on va voir d'ailleurs le
beurre ce qu'il y avait derrière franck
allongement
et d'ailleurs est un non remboursement
non je chante bien un truc
[Applaudissements]
jean-michel pour la storia pour y
remettre celle d'avant c'était bien les
deux
bah oui oui à newark
qu'est ce qu'il a vu à douar anwar et
franck dit non tu parlais juste de votre
cabine à nous arriverons à nous à quoi
j'ai vu d'une très très lourd web troc
et si vous avez vu ici c'est bien ici
c'est bien très bien
iad sabrina manic six mois j'ai eu eric
d'après louis cyrille moi j'ai vu ce
qu'il ya dedans vous allez faire votre
jeu mais j'ai un débrief de ce qui vient
de se passer de gamme je prends de
franck jean-michel on va regarder
d'abord qu'il y avait ici c'est quoi le
débrief l'a écoutée et un débrief quand
même c'est toi tu es formidable votre
prénom c'est comment maintenant plus
oui merci corrida à koriyama raconté
sainz et son corps est justement on a
ouvert le rideau
moi j'étais à la hauteur de gori
[Applaudissements]
toutefois comme un fait ça
même si pour une fois mis d'accord il
merci j'adorais le dos